hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive
over the next half an hour we're going
to be talking through the headlines with
the daily express columnist carol malone
and the and liam thorpe political editor
of the liverpool echo so very good
evening to both of you nice to see you
both
hello lovely to see you thank you very
much let's take a look then what's
making the front pages and the
metro leads with a warning from a
government scientific advisor that
lockdown should not be eased too soon
and there's no quick fix for covid
on the front of the daily telegraph
pandemic risks repeat of 1930s chaos
says forces chief millions in nhs limbo
the eye reporting that nearly a quarter
of a million people have been waiting
over a year
for routine hospital procedures
the times warns that although lockdown
could be eased social distancing rules
could remain
guilty writes the yorkshire post as a
man is convicted of the rape and murder
of
21 year old student libby squire
the mirror leads with tributes to libby
squire to from her family
road plans in doubt on the front of the
guardian the paper reporting that the
transport secretary
overrode official advice they say
and the financial times leads with
details of the plan by the billionaire
brothers
mussin and zuba issa to buy supermarket
giant asda
so carol malone and liam thorpe here
with me to go through some of those
headlines and uh carol you've
well you want to kick off with the metro
and the headline there is there's
no quick fix this is a warning from
a sage advisor to the government isn't
it
yeah it's jerry farah who's a senior
government advisor what he's basically
saying is that
um you know boris was gonna make his
lockdown
exit strategy public on february the
22nd and jeremy farah is basically
saying
you know don't do that it doesn't make
any sense but you know
boris has got to stop being led by
scientists this is not a scientist's job
to dictate government policy you know
we've
boris has got to listen to the signs yes
but you know
covert deaths are down by a third
currently the the case rate is down by
70 we're currently doing a thousand
injections
every is it every minute or something
yes a thousand
vaccinations a minute and and death
rates are tumbling infection rates are
tumbling
what do these scientists want do they
want a world where there is zero covered
because we know that is never going to
happen
they're saying there's no quick fix but
we have to get out
of lofter you know scientists have
already said that this
covet is going to be endemic but every
time there's talk of easing restrictions
they keep on bringing up another
variance they can vary in the bristol
variant
it'll be the scum thorpe variant next
you know they're
you know viruses always mutate so far
there have been
4 000 variants identified covert
variants
unless they're gonna kill us unless
they're gonna unless that
they don't work against our current
vaccines don't keep telling the
population and terrorizing us
because it is not an option to stay in
lockdown
permanently and i think this is just yet
another way
for for the scientists to keep us
unlocked and boris has to start leading
soon
he's our leader he's got to decide when
when we come out and lock down
not the scientists you're shaking your
head liam what do you make of that
carol won't be surprised to hear me
disagree with absolutely everything that
she just said there
i i don't really understand this
argument about why the scientists would
want to keep us unlocked down
i i often get accused of of wanting
people to stay in lockdown because i
think it's the right thing at this
exact moment nobody wants to be on
lockdown it's a terrible thing but for
everyone
i think what what i'm really concerned
about is the same mistakes being
repeated again
carol says that she shouldn't be led by
the scientists well actually
the government is not listened to the
scientists too many times before
in september sage said that we needed to
go into a lockdown at that exact moment
boris johnson delayed and we ended up in
a bad situation again
if we come out too early we will just
end up in lockdown
again we we desperately need this to be
the last lockdown
vaccination liam what is the point of
the vaccine rollout
if we're going to stay in perpetual
lockdown once we
accidentally all the vulnerable people
we're not we're not going to stay a
perpetual lockdown but we need to get as
many people vaccinated as possible and
bring the rates right down because
unfortunately the nhs will just come
back under severe pressure
again you know
from personal experience yeah it is easy
but if we if we came out now
for example in liverpool the infection
rate is still 260 cases per
100 000 people if we came out now that
would explode again it's already much
higher than
when leicester went into lockdown in the
summer for example so the case rates are
still very very very high
yes yes we're starting to see them come
down although they've plateaued a little
bit recently
we're not coming down they're tumbling
and boris was going to make his
announcement on february the 22nd
things are changing very quickly now and
and he shouldn't
be put off from making announcements on
the 22nd because the situation is
changing daily
it's getting better daily what happened
with christmas he
over promised he over-promised in late
november
told everybody that we're gonna have a
five-day free-for-all at christmas and
look i think even you carol
would have to admit that it was an
absolute disaster and we saw an
explosion in cases in january
and we've now had the in parts of the
country about the deadliest month of the
pandemic
we want to avoid ever having to go
through that again and if that means
having to stay in it
sorry i didn't mean to cut you off liam
but i was just going to move us on to
the next story because it is connected
and carol
this is in the daily telegraph they're
saying a school return date
must be signed in blood and inverted
commerce and presumably this is pressure
from
boris johnson's back benchers worried
that that date of march the eighth
that's been muted might slip
yes and and this this is the point of
because and with what
pharah has said tonight and and probably
the other
sage people will back him up on what he
has said tonight
what mps are worried about is this is
going to put off boris
reopening the schools on march the
eighth and they're they're trying to
persuade boris
not to make any announcement on the 22nd
i think there it could be the 22nd or
any time that week and they're trying to
persuade him
not to do that and which means that
that date for the opening of schools may
slip you know
we can't keep schools clean now boris is
going to have a lot of trouble anyway
getting the schools reopened
because of the you need opposition
they're making incredible demands before
teachers go back to school full-time i
mean some of them are unreasonable
demands
i mean especially when we have we see a
lot of um public health
sorry public service workers have been
at work throughout lockdown
and have not complained the way the
teaching unions have
but you know this we have got to get our
children back to school we can't
keep putting off it's been nearly a year
now and a year out of education
is massive in a child's life well yes
and the government has all along
liam talked about it being a priority to
get kids into school if at all possible
but there does seem to be
a lot of caution this time around there
does seem to be a lot of concern
about infection rates i i'm actually
pleased that for the first time in this
whole crisis
i think that the prime minister is
adopting a more cautious approach
i i completely understand and i
completely agree
that the absolute priority is to get
kids back into school as soon as
possible because
certainly for many in deprived areas
online learning is just not a
possibility
we're going to see that attainment gap
grow in ways that we really don't need
to
however as i've said before if we if we
move too quickly
then we end up in another lockdown and
you know we that's the last thing any of
us need that's the last thing our kids
need that's the last thing anybody needs
so i am actually pleased to see a little
bit more caution from the prime minister
than we have seen in previous times
i think it's now widely assumed that we
went we we were too late into the first
lockdown too late into the second two
late into the third
and we're now paying for that
the vaccine now we have the vaccine why
are we being super cautious
when we've already vaccinated most of
our vulnerable people
in the next few weeks we're gonna we're
gonna vaccinated everyone's okay
after that we should not quit quick come
back on that liam
there's still a lot of questions about
the the current impact of the vaccine
you heard
patrick valen say it the other day we
need to see what its effects are on
transmissibility
we need to see what it's affects our own
death rate obviously things are looking
good in that
in that department but if we move too
quickly we don't know what's going to
happen
we do not want to end up in a situation
again so a little bit more caution now
is what's needed and then hopefully
we're all in a better position in a few
months time
okay and let's move on to the eye
millions in nhs limbo
figures out today talking about the
number of people on waiting lists for
routine
procedures they say it's the highest
number since record began in 2007
carol a huge pressure on the nhs because
the number of people in hospital at the
moment with
covid yeah you know the numbers of
people
waiting for more than a year for what
was supposed to be urgent treatment has
rocketed in december that we've got the
figures for december
to 224 205.
now though compare those figures to 2019
and there was 1 000 it was 467 people
waiting
look at i can't even work out the
percentage of what that is now you know
we
we keep on talking about covert deaths
and yes every one of them is tragic
but you know we haven't begun to think
about the people who are going to die
because of cancers undetected cancers or
cancers that are being detected which
just
aren't going to be treated heart disease
all sorts of
illnesses okay the death toll will be
more than the curvature okay and i want
to let
liam quickly make a comment on this
before we go to the break liam
yeah i mean it's it's a disaster when
you think about it in terms of the the
number of people who are waiting for
urgent
urgent care i do think sometimes the
argument is framed wrong though i think
it's seen as
these these conditions against the
lockdown it's not
our nhs has been on the brink of being
overwhelmed by
a a killer virus that we never knew
about before it's not a case of
making those choices the nhs is
obviously doing what it can to try and
balance these things out
and it's it's a terrible situation but
it but it but it's not lockdown that's
stopping these treatments it's covid19
okay we are going to take a pause right
there and plenty more to get our teeth
into in just a moment including
motorway death reignites the debate over
smart motorways we're going to be
discussing that in a moment
doctors are taught to not give of
themselves because if we give of
ourselves
always there will be nothing left for us
and so we do have
a wall but patients really appreciate
the human
and they really want to see that
sometimes and so it's
about striking the balance between
giving enough that patients feel
listened to
and feel that you understand them while
still protecting yourself and actually i
think that that's something that we need
to be teaching medical students much
more because the difficulties with the
wall versus the human
are essentially why one of the reasons
why we think so many doctors have mental
health problems because it
is such a difficult balance but patients
really do seem to appreciate
the fact that i truly understand now of
course it's still about them it's not
about me
but just knowing that somebody gets it
can make real difference
[Music]
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
more flares going off a volley of rocks
bubbles have been pulled up out and are
being used as missiles of hell
at these
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place
for news we have now
left italy and entered france nobody's
asked to check our identity
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr barney
why committing you fishing does have the
potential
to stymie an enormous economic deal
what strikes you when you come to this
glacier is not just the way in which the
environment
is changing but the speed at which those
changes are happening
it's uh devastating actually
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast but wherever you
are welcome to
safety ridge podcast for the ones who
want to know more welcome to the all-out
politics podcast
for the listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free welcome back you're watching
the press preview
with me tonight daily express columnist
carol malone and liam thorpe political
editor
of the liverpool echo welcome back to
both of you karen you picked out a story
on the front of the yorkshire post next
and this is over a death on a smart
motorway so
what's the yorkshire post telling us
this is this is a really tragic story
and it's not
the first time that there has been a
catastrophe with these smartweb
motorways but this
this was a lady a 62 year old lady
called
um nargis bagoon and she her car
broke down uh on on a stretch of the m1
on a live lane
and and she she broke down where
the the hard shoulder would have been
before they took it away
and she was standing there she she
called for help and she was standing
there
for more than 15 minutes before highways
england put the warning signs on but she
was tragically
hit you know she was she was she was hit
and killed
now this is just appalling and now the
story is that highways england
could face charges of criminal charges
maybe even charges
for manslaughter because of this lady's
death and you know it's
something like this needs to happen for
the highways agency for this government
to look
at what they have done on our motorways
cars are always going to break down
they have to have somewhere to go to be
pushed to
while they're waiting for help the signs
overhead that are supposed to
warn people about this they work
probably 90 odd percent of the time but
they don't work all of the time and
because they weren't working on this
particular day
this lady is now dead and her family
have to face a lifetime of their day
it's
you know whoever invented these
motorways who have thought about them
and even when they were
first mooted there were so many
objections to them people said that
they wouldn't work and that this would
happen and they were ignored and now
look
you know there's going to have to be
some kind of change here where they
where they change it back and give us a
lane where people can go
to be safe okay yes and it's certainly a
a
a debate that we're hearing a lot at the
moment it'd be interesting to see if
there are developments on that
and we're turning to the front page of
the daily mirror next
um aren't we liam um and this a a very
sad front page
our wonderful girl will always be with
us this is libby squire
um and her murderer found guilty today
yeah and and it's you know absolutely
right to see the mirror going very big
on this
it's such an utterly tragic story and
and
and i'm pleased to see the mirror come
at this from the the angle of the mum
of libby spy it's just absolutely every
parent's nightmare
you know your child goes off to
university for to have the time in their
lives and to hear like something like
this happen
it and some of the the details that have
come out in the case are horrific
in terms of some of the other crimes
that relevations has been involved in
um voyeurism and and sexual
crimes and and there are perhaps some
questions for police to answer
there's been some suggestion that
perhaps there was a pattern of behavior
there
however you know sometimes hindsight is
is a a good thing
when you're looking at the case and the
details as a whole all we can say is
that
libby sounds like an absolutely
wonderful young woman been described as
wickedly funny
an amazing young woman and she's been
taken from her family and and
it's i think it was the longest running
investigation um that humble side police
have carried out and so at least it's
something that that we've been able to
get a conviction today but as
libby's mum said today it doesn't do
anything to bring her daughter back so
it's just an utterly tragic case
and and one that i think will will stay
in people's minds for a long time
indeed desperately sad homicide police
say though that
there's nothing more that they could
have done given the information that
they had at the time they say
we are going to leave it there i'm
pleased to say you'll both be back at 11
30. lots more to talk about then but for
the moment
carolyn in thank you